and i've also been an extreme people
pleaser
when someone would get upset or angry
with me or didn't like something or
whatever they had a different point of
view and they wanted me to do their
thing
i would give in over and over again
because they were angry and upset at me
and so i would just give in and say okay
what do you want what do you need let me
do this
fine and i would do it from a place of i
don't want to do this i'm
i'm out of integrity with myself but i'm
doing it to keep the peace
and i used to say man this person
doesn't understand me they keep
attacking me they're not happy with who
i am and be upset at them
then i realized oh this isn't about them
this is about me
abandoning myself me not standing up for
what i want or what i believe in this
moment
not saying that they're right or bad or
wrong or anything i'm not saying i'm
right or wrong but just
we want different things in this moment
but i would always abandon
myself to make someone else happy to
create
a sense of peace in that moment and what
i've learned is you can't buy peace
you can't pay someone off for them to
then be happy because then they'll keep
doing it